OK, so you know how I said that
this lesson was going to
be the one where we're going
to add a sign in button?
Well, it turns out I lied.
This lesson is where we add in
all the frameworks and all the
linker flags and do all the
random setup stuff we have to
do before we add the
sign in button.
But I promise, after this,
we'll be adding a button.
It'll be really exciting.
So let's get into adding
our frameworks.
Now, the first thing we're
going to want to do is
download the Play Games SDK
and the Google+ SDK.
We're going to make use of both
of these libraries in our
application.
So first thing we're going to
do is go to developers.googl
e.com/games/services.
And once that page pops up,
we're going to go to the
Downloads link here
on the left.
Now, on this page, you'll see
a link to the Games SDK.
By the time you see this
tutorial, this will probably
say version 1.1.
You can click on this link, and
this will download a ZIP
file to somewhere in
your local drive.
Once that's done, you're going
to want to follow this Google+
iOS SDK link, and this will take
you to the Downloads page
for the Google+ platform.
If we scroll down to the bottom,
you'll see a link for
the Google+ iOS SDK,
and we can download
the ZIP file as well.
Once that's done, you'll have a
downloads folder that looks
a little something like this.
We've got our Google+ SDK and
our PlayGamesServices SDK.
And so first thing you're going
to want to do is unzip
each of these.
And then, I suppose we can trash
the ZIP files just to
clean up a little space.
Great, and now we have
some frameworks we
can add to our project.
Now, we're going to leave this
PlayGamesServices alone for a
little while, but let's
explore what's in
our Google+ iOS SDK.
You'll see in here, we've got
a couple of frameworks along
with a bundle file and this open
source directory, along
with the changelog, readme file,
and some sample code.
For the purposes of our
application, we're going to
want to add the two frameworks
into our Xcode project.
So the easiest way to do that
is, let's go to Xcode.
And we can simply drag these two
framework folders into our
Xcode project.
So I'm going to copy over the
GoogleOpenSource.framework folder.
And depending on your setup,
you may want to copy these
into your destination folder.
Or, you might want to leave
this unchecked if, for
instance, you have a centralized
location where all
of your libraries
are going to be.
Then you can have multiple
applications all referring to
the same directory.
And at some point in the future,
when you need to
update this directory, this
framework, you'll only need to
update it in one place.
On the other hand, if you need
to put everything into a nice,
stand-alone folder that you can
zip up and send around,
maybe it's worth copying this
into your destination folder.
In my case, I'm going to leave
this checked and copy
everything over.
And then I'm going to
do the same thing
for the Google+ framework.
And again, I'll leave
this checked.
Make sure that the GuessMyNumber
target is
checked as well.
And look at that, we've got two
new frameworks added to
our project.
I'm just going to move these
into the frameworks folder.
And we can take a minute to talk
about the few things that
we're not adding.
You'll notice we have a
GooglePlus.bundle file that
we're not going to copy over.
This contains all the resources
needed to generate
an in-game Google+
sign in button.
And for reasons that I'll
explain in a future lesson,
we're actually not going to
take advantage of this.
We're going to generate
our own.
But if you were to use the
official Google+ sign in
button, you would also want
to copy over this bundle.
In addition, there's an
OpenSource folder.
This OpenSource folder contains
the source code
versions of everything that is
in your GoogleOpenSource
framework folder.
The framework folder tends to be
a little easier to add into
your application.
You just kind of drag it
in, and you're done.
But I know that some developers
like to have the
open source folder with
all the source code
added to their project.
They may want to do this so
they can get in there and
debug what's happening, if their
program is running into
issues, by going off into
the open source library.
There have been a few bug
workarounds in the past I've
had to implement where we
actually needed to alter or
add things to the open
source folder
instead of the framework.
So there may be times
you want to do this.
However, in our case, to keep
things simple, we're just
going to stick with
the framework.
But feel free if you'd
like to add the open
source directory instead.
You definitely want to
add one or the other.
Don't add both, or my guess is
you'll end up with a bunch of
those duplicate symbol errors.
So the next thing we're going
to want to do to get this
library to work is add this kind
of obscure linker flag
into our project.
So I'm going to go to this
target, and under Build
Settings, I'm going to
search for linker.
And here, Other Linker Flags,
I'm going to double-click this
and add ObjC as our
linker flag.
You need to do this to get
the frameworks working.
And if you're working, how would
I ever figure out that
this flag needs to be set
for things to work?
This is all available on
our documentation.
We walk you through all this,
step by step, on the iOS
quickstart guide.
So please be sure to check that
out if you ever need a
review of what's going
on in this video.
So we're going to add that.
And then, the final thing we
need to do is add in our
custom URL type.
If you'll recall from our
presentation, we need to
register with the system.
That com.google.Guess
MyNumber:/oauth2callback is a
URI that corresponds
to our application.
And the way to do that is in
Xcode, in a feature that maybe
you've never used
before, which is
adding custom URL types.
So let's show you
how to do that.
Go back to Xcode, and in the
Info tab, this URL Types, a
drop-down will expand.
We can hit the plus sign to
create our own custom one, and
this identifier will be your
bundle identifier which, in my
case, is
com.google.GuessMyNumber.
But in your case, it probably
has your own company name
instead of Google.
And we'll add the same thing
for a URL scheme.
So just copy and paste that.
And we can leave it at that.
That's good enough.
At that point, we've now
basically told the system,
hey, if you see any URL
that begins with
com.google.GuessMyNumber instead
of HTTP or mailto,
that means go to our
application.
And finally, let's add a
few other frameworks
we're going to need.
So go to your Build Phases tab,
and under Link Binary
With Libraries, hit
the plus sign.
And we're going to add
SystemConfiguration.framework.
We can also add
Security.framework.
And then, let's add a few other
frameworks that we don't
need for sign in but we're going
to need for the game's
SDK in a couple of lessons.
So I'm going to add
CoreData.framework.
I'm going to add
CoreText.framework.
And finally, let's add
QuartzCore.framework.
We can drag all these to our
Frameworks folder, just to
keep everything nice and neat.
And there we go.
The setup steps are
finally done.
And now, in the next lesson, for
real, honest, I promise,
maybe, we can add a
sign in button.